and here we are uh in the piazza mika
which is the small square
where we have the book festival
which is part of the larger
um
theater festival that's taking place
here in cebu and i just bought a book
and i'm going to interview the lady who
sold me the book
and but i'm going to wait till she has a
second because she's busy
right now with her customers and i don't
want to disturb her i bought a book
here called
i don't again it's so sunny i can't see
where this is coming through but it's
called
de chile is
why is romania different and in reading
this book i will learn about romania and
at the same time i will improve my
romanian because at a certain point
uh you have to read away from the
computer
and you have to read books and books on
subjects of interest because i find that
uh as i've struggled to speak romanian
over the last uh two three days here
i've become increasingly aware
of where my problems are and then i i'm
able to notice them
when i read so let's see if we can find
a couple of
uh
minutes here
okay
okay
oh she bought the same book
as i did but i don't want to
cause her to lose business here so i'll
just back away
and then we'll continue again
and actually i was at that bookstore
last night i must say i'm a big reader
of books
because it really is
the best way
to learn languages
um
uh
um
hi there steve kaufman uh
i'm back in vancouver after my uh eight
day trip to uh
vienna and romania
uh it's been a long day i uh
got a plane at seven in the morning out
of cebu into munich hung around munich
airport
uh got on a plane at about 3 30 got into
vancouver about 5 30 which is uh about
five hours ago i'm fading fast tomorrow
morning i have to get up early my wife
and i are going over to vancouver island
for three days of golfing with some
friends
so i won't have much time to
get into details or to organize some of
the videos
uh that i did in romania that i took
uh but i'm going to tag one of them on
to the end of this um
i apologize that the poor quality of the
video because i was speaking to this
lady who was manning this uh
booth selling books and she had other
customers and the sun was right on me i
couldn't really tell whether i had my
iphone centered on her face which in
many cases i didn't you'll notice as you
see the video but it gives you some of
the flavor uh sibiu was very lively lots
of people in the streets during the day
in the evening
lots of sunshine we even had some rain
and some hail and if i get around i'll
put those videos up for you as well
uh delightful place to visit and the
whole of my experience in romania was
phenomenal we were i was up north in red
oats where i saw of course a sawmill
which relates to my business
but also visited a monastery
and uh
just
got a bit of the flavor of the people
very friendly then drove from there
i rented uh in fact i rented a car and
for an extra 20 euros a day you get a
driver which i figured would be a good
idea because it's basically
two lane highways one lane in each
direction and lots of trucks and i
didn't want to be worrying about when to
pass cars and where to go so
that was great i had a nice chat with my
driver the whole way
and then i was in komanesht which is uh
south in in moldova and had a lovely
dinner there ate lots of brunza and mama
liga
and drank some tuica
and the next morning uh
drove from there via the mountains
via
pietro nyamt
and i can't remember the name bezoc
because there's something there was a la
roche up through the mountains and it's
very rocky on the one side and you get
over to the other side and it's heavily
forested and then into a plateau
and through to segeswara and then cebu
the scenery changed every uh seems every
half hour hour or so and i had a
wonderful time
uh romania is a beautiful country it's
very green
uh people are very friendly um it's not
you know exactly uh you know the
economically they're having their
troubles a lot of people who go overseas
to work um
and send money back you see a lot of new
homes being built by
these people who have been working in
italy and spain
anyway i'll get into more detail uh save
you is all of it well worth a visit in
particular cebu but but other parts of
it as well
and um
i'll just tag on this little bit of
video and i apologize for the fact that
the person that i interview uh basically
has her face cut off from the nose up
for much of the video and when i get
back i what i will do is i'll probably
try to line up a discussion with my uh
romanian tutor and we'll have a
conversation in romanian and i'll tell
her about all the things that i saw and
did in romania and that should be lively
and and
the question is can i be fluent uh after
two months of studying at link
and uh for uh
four days in the country the answer is
no
but i can communicate absolutely no
problem i have very few situations where
i couldn't communicate i understand what
people are saying
i bought
books which i read on the flight home um
yeah
it's not fluency but you'll see when i
interview
this uh my tutor probably on the weekend
or early next week okay then and watch
this video bye for now